lo que le vengo a proponer esta tarde es
que nos preguntemos hacerles una
propuesta
que sepan que todo el universo está
conectado por un flujo de elementos un
flujo de elementos químicos que puede
determinar de acuerdo a cómo lo usemos y
que está influenciado por los seres
humanos
puede influenciar
en la posibilidad de que siga de que
sigamos o no existiendo como especie en
este planeta se humilde dice un
proverbio serbio pues estás hecho de
tierra
se noble pues estás hecho de estrellas
la propuesta que les traigo hoy
es hacer un viaje
una especie de food main es químico
donde los que vamos a tomar conciencia
va a ser de los elementos químicos que
forman forman parte que estamos formados
partes y que forman parte cada una de
las cosas que nos rodean
todos tenemos un teléfono celular si
toquemos nuestros teléfonos celulares de
los 90 elementos de esta tabla periódica
73 forman parte de este teléfono celular
este teléfono celular es inorgánico
compuesto por elementos químicos
inorgánicos como el cobre cobalto níquel
carbono
ahora cerremos los ojos
inspiramos
estamos incorporando oxígeno dos
moléculas de oxígeno expire mos estamos
largando dos moléculas de dióxido de
carbono carbono y dos moléculas de
oxígeno
toquemos nuestro pelo
nuestro pelo está formado por queratina
la queratina es una proteína que tiene
carbono nitrógeno oxígeno hidrógeno
y azufre ahora toquemos el hueso de
nuestra mandíbula ese hueso de mandíbula
también es una proteína formada por
carbono nitrógeno oxígeno hidrógeno
azufre pero también tiene fosfato de
calcio por eso es dura el fosfato del
calcio es carbono y fósforo
sigamos con los ojos cerrados y pensemos
en todos estos elementos que les acabo
de nombrar
e imaginemos que todos esos elementos
que yo les acabo de nombrar vienen del
polvo de las estrellas
carl sagan es un gran divulgador
científico por el cual me volví
científica los de mi generación se
acuerdan de la serie cosmos sí y él
decía
tenía la frase que decía somos polvo de
estrellas pensando o reflexionando sobre
las estrellas
esta frase icónica de este gran
divulgador científico no es una frase
poética es una frase científica de hecho
estamos hechos de polvo de estrellas y
de dónde viene ese polvo de estrellas
ese polvo de estrellas viene de una de
tres procesos
el primer proceso es el big-bang
la gran explosión hace 313 mil 800
millones de años en la cual se formó el
universo en esa gran explosión a medida
que se fue enfriando se empezó a formar
el helio y el hidrógeno si mediante
condensación gravitacional se empezaron
a formar las primeras estrellas las
estrellas se las conoce también como
hornos solares porque dentro de las
estrellas hay tanta energía y tanto
calor que ocurre la núcleos intereses la
fusión por núcleo síntesis o sea que los
átomos empiezan a unirse entre sí y
empiezan a formar todos los elementos de
la tabla periódica hasta el hierro
pero quedan ahí porque ya no pueden
formar elementos más pesados porque no
hay suficiente energía para formar
elementos más pesados como el oro por
ejemplo cuando se forman todo el resto
de las tablas en la siguiente etapa esa
siguiente etapa es la gran explosión de
las supernovas cuando una estrella se
acaba si ocurren las supernovas que es
una gran explosión en la cual todos los
elementos que se habían formado en el
núcleo de esa estrella son dispersados
por el universo y además con esa gran
cantidad de energía fruto de esa
explosión se forma el resto de los
elementos
así como el zinc el cobre el oro la
plata etcétera
hasta aquí
creo haberlos convencido que estamos
hechos de polvo de estrellas
ahora lo importante es que tengamos la
conciencia si yo les presentó esta nueva
tabla periódica que la mayor parte de lo
que nos rodea viene o del big band
o de las grandes estrellas o de las
supernovas
ahora vamos a seguir haciendo un viaje
vamos vengamos del universo nos vengamos
al planeta y aquí en el planeta vamos a
hacer un viaje primero con una molécula
de calcio esa molécula del calcio formó
parte de un trilobite los trilobites
eran como cucarachas marinas que
habitaban en el paleozoico el fondo de
los océanos en ese estilo viste esa
molécula de calcio estaba en ese
trilobite en ese trilobite en forma
orgánica porque formaba parte de la vida
si es ese trilobite cuando muere forma
parte de vuelta de los sedimentos si
pasa a la cadena biológica a través de
una planta de una bacteria sí y después
de muchos años forma parte de un gran
gigantosaurio que ha visto por ejemplo
la patagonia argentina pre dando
en la patagonia argentina s
gigantosaurus murió volvió otra vez a la
tierra y después fue parte de un
gliptodonte ya en la era del cuaternario
en el palio se en el pleistoceno que
pastaba por la pradera sudamericana
cuando s s s
listo donde deja de existir esa molécula
de calcio vuelve a la tierra y capaz que
es adquirida o forma parte del hueso de
uno de los conquistadores de américa y
después pasa a uno de los habitantes del
pd monta de la del pedemonte tucumano y
de ahí capaz que pasó al hueso de
nuestra mandíbula
estamos hablando de ciclos los cuales
los elementos que son inorgánicos y
orgánicos
felicitaciones se acaban de aprender lo
que es un ciclo biogeoquímico parecía
difícil no no no lo es estamos
aprendiendo ciencia
ahora quienes están involucrados en
todos esos procesos biogeoquímicos estos
pueden ser procesos en los cuales se van
reciclando en forma en forma geológica
en forma química pero los principales
degradadores los principales motores de
estos ciclos biogeoquímicos son los
microbios
de hecho los microbios son los que por
ejemplo en el caso del fósforo que es
cuando está inorgánico el fósforo
inorgánico y después forma parte de las
plantas lo hacen disponible gracias a
los microbios
los microbios dominan y dominaron el
planeta los microbios son unicelulares
no todos los microbios producen
enfermedades de hecho la mayoría y
estamos vivos estamos en este planeta
gracias a los microbios si nosotros
tomamos la historia de la vida del plan
en el planeta como un reloj la parte
marrón si casi 45 minutos 50 minutos
estuvo dominada exclusivamente por
microbios
estamos hablando de alrededor de 3500
millones de años en los últimos 10
minutos aparecen las plantas y los
animales y en los últimos segundos
aparecemos nosotros los seres humanos
de hecho los microbios durante tres mil
millones de años dominaron el planeta y
fueron los primeros fueron los expertos
en reciclar polvo de estrellas porque el
planeta primitivo no tenía oxígeno no
tenía capa de ozono en el planeta
primitivo los continentes se estaban
formando había grandes volcanes hay
muchísima actividad volcánica y estaba
la sopa primitiva donde surgió la vida
que era una sopa alcalina salina cargada
de elementos químicos cargadas de polvo
de estrellas y los microbios aprendieron
a reciclar ya tomar energía y a producir
comida pasar de inorgánico a orgánico en
esa sopa primitiva ellos fueron los
expertos en hacer esto y como lo
hicieron se asociaron se asociaron
formando colonias esas piedritas que ven
ahí se llaman estromatolitos los
estromatolitos
son asociaciones de algas y bacterias
que son los expertos en transformar lo
inorgánico en orgánico tomar el dióxido
de carbono sí y transformarlo en una
molécula de azúcar vamos a decirlo como
una forma muy simple e incorporarlo a la
materia orgánica si eso lo hicieron
durante tres mil millones de años
produjeron materia orgánica liberaron
oxígeno primero saturaron los mares
después la atmósfera crearon la capa de
ozono y prepararon el planeta para que
exista otras formas de vida como las
plantas y los animales que dominaron el
planeta gracias a los cambios que
hicieron los estromatolitos
en esos últimos 500 millones de años ya
estamos hablando de los últimos 10
minutos de ese reloj donde había plantas
y animales ocurrieron cinco extinciones
masivas
esas cinco extinciones masivas fueron
porque hubo un desequilibrio en los
ciclos geoquímicos del planeta ya
sabemos lo que son los ciclos
biogeoquímicos y normalmente se daban
esas extinciones masivas por exceso de
dióxido de carbono ya sea porque
impactaba un meteorito en el planeta o
porque había una gran erupción volcánica
si ocurría que cambiaban todas las
condiciones del planeta todas las
condiciones del clima y la mayoría de la
flora y la fauna se extinguía
y quienes aparecían a arreglar la
situación los estromatolitos otra vez
dominaban el planeta captaba en el
dióxido de carbono liberaban oxígeno y
volvían a producir las condiciones para
que haya la evolución de nuevas formas
de vida
la última gran extinción masiva fue la
de las de los de los dinosaurios gracias
a esa extinción masiva ya que se fueron
todos los grandes dinosaurios aparecimos
nosotros los mamíferos que ahora estamos
dominando el planeta con nuestra especie
homo sapiens y estamos empujando a
través del calentamiento global al
planeta a la próxima extinción
vamos a seguir viajando ya que hemos
viajado al planeta primitivo ahora vamos
a viajar a la puna la puna es un
desierto de altura que está ubicado
entre argentina chile y bolivia arriba
de los 3000 metros sobre el nivel del
mar y está plagada de salares y volcanes
activos la puna tiene la característica
de tener un parecido con la tierra
primitiva como estamos muy alto arriba
de los 3.600 metros sobre el nivel del
mar tenemos mucha radiación ultravioleta
primera coincidencia tenemos muchísima
actividad volcánica otra coincidencia
tenemos muy pocas formas de vida porque
las condiciones ahí son muy extremas y
las que los organismos que sobreviven en
esas condiciones se llaman extremófilos
sí y tenemos lagunas donde el agua es
muy salina muy alcalina y cargada de
arsénico y además en el año 2009
nosotros encontramos otra coincidencia
con nuestro grupo de laboratorio del
conicet
yo soy investigador del conicet
encontramos estromatolitos vivos
encontramos fósiles vivos viviendo en
unas condiciones parecidas a la de ese
planeta primitivo
los encontramos en los volcanes a los
bordes de las lagunas y en los salares
hace 10 años que venimos estudiando
estromatolitos que estamos
estromatolitos la puna literalmente pase
de 10 años arriba de una camioneta 4x4
recorriendo todos los salares de
argentina chile y bolivia buscando donde
había y donde no para hacer un reporte
para reportarlos para la ciencia
hemos encontrado alrededor de 35 lugares
donde encontramos este tipo de
ecosistemas en argentina chile y bolivia
pero principalmente lo que hicimos fue
hacer ciencia publicamos muchísimas
publicaciones científicas y lo principal
que encontramos en todas esas
publicaciones fue esto
permítanme presentarles el árbol de la
vida donde luca es el ancestro común de
todas las formas de vida last y unique
como un ancestro
luca es la primera bacteria la primera
proto bacteria que habita este planeta
que tenía mecanismos para soportar las
condiciones de la tierra primitiva a
partir de esas bacterias evolucionó la
vida de las bacterias las arqueas los
eucariotas que son las plantas y los
animales
nuestra investigación en estos últimos
12 años nos cuenta
que las bacterias que viven en los
estromatolitos de la puna funcionan
igual que lucas usan los mismos
mecanismos que usa lucas que se cree que
usó luca o sea que están funcionando
como funcionaban esos antiguos
recicladores de polvos de estrellas hace
3.500 millones de años
de hecho lo que encontramos fue que
todos los ciclos geoquímicos
biogeoquímicos que hay en el planeta se
pueden encontrar en unos pocos
milímetros de un estromatolito de la
puna si funcionando como hace tres mil
quinientos millones de años
hemos enseñado todo esto a las
comunidades y hemos involucrado a las
comunidades en la preservación de estos
ecosistemas estas son las publicaciones
a las que yo le mostré antes son
científicas estas son las publicaciones
que hicieron las comunidades para
proteger a sus estromatolitos yo tengo
más orgullo de estas que de las
anteriores
también nos involucramos con todas las
empresas mineras sobre todo las empresas
que hacen explotación de litio en la
zona de los salares para que por primera
vez los microorganismos sean
considerados parte de los estudios de
impacto ambiental y las líneas de base
logramos dos áreas protegidas una en
laguna socompa en salta y la otra en el
salar de atacama en chile todas estas
declaraciones de áreas protegidas
basadas en microorganismos fue hecho con
las comunidades originarias
también hemos hecho una ruta de turismo
científico para que se llama ruta al
origen de la vida para mostrar cómo
podría haber sido este planeta primitivo
y entonces llegó la transformación
el año pasado todo se transformó todos
nos transformamos todos nos tuvimos que
transformar y así como una molécula de
fósforo en forma parte del suelo se
transforma en una molécula en forma
parte de una molécula de adn de un ser
vivo me transformé yo
y de ser bióloga de ser científica de
ciencia básica me transformé en
biotecnología cambia mi forma de ver el
mundo cambia mi forma de interpretar la
naturaleza y en vez de preguntarte de
preguntarme cómo hacen los
microorganismos para sobrevivir esas
condiciones extremas cambie la forma de
ver las cosas y cambie la pregunta cómo
podemos usar ese conocimiento para
resolver los problemas de este planeta
porque si hay algo que nos dejó la
pandemia es la idea que estamos todos en
el mismo barco y que aquí nadie se salva
y la ciencia y la tecnología es
realmente la única herramienta que puede
ayudar a salir a salir de esta situación
el primer cambio fue ver a los salares
de un punto de vista diferente los
salares en esas extensiones blancas
áridas que siempre fueron consideradas
estériles están vivos están habitados
por microorganismos extremófilos por
microorganismos que soportan las
condiciones extremas principalmente de
sequedad de salinidad de bajo oxígeno de
muchísima radiación ultravioleta los
salares están vivos y tienen muchísimos
secretos que contar uno de los secretos
que nos contaron los salares
estudiándolos es cómo hacen las
bacterias de los salares esas bacterias
recicladoras de polvo de estrellas que
están funcionando desde hace 3.500
millones de años como hacen para ayudar
a las plantas a crecer en los salares
eso es conocimiento de ciencia básica
pero también puede tener una aplicación
y así fue que nos incubamos en una se
llama incubadora de empresas incubadora
de ideas grid ex es una incubadora de
ideas lo que hace grid es buscar a lo
largo del país es es una incubadora
argentina que busca a lo largo del país
tiene alrededor de 1.700 proyectos busca
ideas científicas y todos los años de
100 ideas científicas que hacemos
científicos como yo dos científicos de
las universidades en todo el país
incluso científicos de latinoamérica
si nos incuba que significa que nos
incuba que nos enseña cómo cambiar
nuestra cabeza como pensar que la
ciencia se puede transformar en
biotecnología y en plena pandemia a
través de zoom cuando todo alrededor se
nos venía abajo cambiamos aprendimos de
negocios
conseguimos la inversión fuimos
seleccionados de esos 100 100 proyectos
quedaron 10 de esos 10 proyectos
nuestra empresa fue seleccionada y así
nació acá por kapur es una startup una
startup es una empresa con base
biotecnológica que crece rápido o muere
nuestra stand nuestra startup está
formada por científicos somos tres
científicas que estamos aprendiendo de
negocios y un emprendedor de negocios
que aprende de ciencia y qué es lo que
queremos resolver qué es lo que vamos a
resolver el problema del suelo
el suelo en el planeta sabemos que el 30
por el 33 por ciento del suelo del
planeta no se puede cultivar está
degradado y cada vez somos más los que
necesitamos alimento cada vez la
población necesita más alimento cada vez
se usa más agroquímicos y la solución
que son los productos biológicos
funcionan si funcionan pero no funcionan
en suelo degradado no funcionan en
suelos salinos excepto
quienes los microbios de los salares
estos recicladores de polvos de
estrellas que desde hace millones de
años tienen la tecnología suficiente
como para producir algo así esta es una
foto de la semana pasada una plantación
de soja sin nuestra tecnología y con
nuestra tecnología no sólo eso sino que
además podemos hacer y ayudar a crecer
las plantas en un ambiente salino en una
en un ambiente con poca cantidad de agua
y así hemos creado una una pequeña
startup una pequeña empresa que quizás
haga terminemos siendo un unicornio como
dicen en el mundo de los negocios
quizás terminemos cotizando en bolsa o
quizás no terminemos pasando el año y
terminemos por cuestiones regulatorias o
falta de inversión desapareciendo lo que
sí sabemos es que somos más que además
de ser emprendedores además de ser en
este momento empresarios me suenan raras
son decir que soy empresaria pero es lo
que somos en este momento somos
científicos somos
y madres tenemos hijos y queremos que
este planeta continúe y tenemos una
utopía la utopía es que la tecnología
que hemos desarrollado pueda colaborar a
que se dejen de usar tantos agroquímicos
contaminando la tierra los mares
y el agua en general nuestra utopía es
que el suelo no cultivable se vuelva
cultivable y poder producir más
alimentos para todos en forma
sustentable y así de esa forma tener que
dejar de talar los bosques y dejar de
talar el amazonas' dejar de reforestar y
dejar de producir la la perder los
sumideros de carbono y empujar este
planeta al calentamiento global que
estamos llevando adelante y además que
esta tecnología permita además a tratar
a través del tratado de nagoya que el
dinero que produzca esta tecnología
vuelva a las comunidades originarias que
son las dueñas de los salares y les
permitan tener luz las 24 horas una
ambulancia en la puerta y una serie de
necesidades
nuestra utopía es que la evolución la
bendita evolución la bendita selección
natural que durante miles de millones de
años desarrolló estrategias para
reciclar polvo de estrellas en los
salares y que puede ayudar a crecer las
plantas en ambientes en suelos
degradados y recuperar suelos degradados
y así poder salvar a nuestro planeta de
la extinción al cual lo estamos llevando
que podamos que podamos ser parte de ese
proceso porque en realidad
si nos extinguimos al universo le va a
importar muy poco solamente se va a
encargar
de reciclar nuestro polvo de estrellas y
entre tanto planteo existencial que les
estoy dando ahora les quiero dejar una
idea es que todos somos seres mortales
hechos de polvo de estrellas pasando
fugazmente por este planeta pero cuando
logramos comprender la naturaleza o
cuando logramos desarrollar una pasión
en ese instante sólo por ese instante
nos convertimos en casi dioses yo los
invito esta tarde a que todos busquemos
ese instante muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]